what are you feeling right now and I
said I feel three elephants sitting on
my chest I've had this happen to me
before which I realized that in 2016
when they kept sending me out of the
hospital I'm passing these clots on my
own no medication no nothing so when I
wake up thank God I'll tell you this the
morning of this is a weird thing to
happen to me you got more blood clots in
Kingston
yeah
it's like 4 a.m it's dark as and I
see this black figure at the end of my
bed
it doesn't look like a per there's no
detail but it's just a silhouette that
looks human-ish the silhouette and that
thing reaches out and it touches
the right big toe of my foot what the
hell and shakes it a little bit just a
black figure at the end of your bed
shaking or touches it and then moves off
maybe my right